[Music]
today's question my husband
and i are 27 years and 28 years old we
each have our own small businesses
recently began our debt-free journey
we're in baby step two getting out of
debt and not investing i'm wondering
what is the benefit of investing into a
retirement account
that you can't touch in real till
retirement age as opposed to other
mutual funds with similar growth
that you can access more freely
taxes
let me explain it to you let's say you
know right before the break i said if
you put i mean 100
100 a month away uh from age 25 to 85
you'd have 1 million 176
000 if you put 2 away you'd have 2.2
million 2.4 million
okay so 200 bucks which for most of you
once you're out of debt and have your
emergency fund doesn't even
even equal as much as you should be
which is 15
of your income but let's just use 2
million you get to retirement
casey and you
have been taxed all these years
on all of that money
as it has grown and so in other words
for you to end up what when you would
have ended up with
2.2 million dollars for 200 a month
during the in that example
you would have ended up with a million
dollars
okay let's say you put it into a roth
ira
now 200 a month is 2400
a year for 40 years is like
80 grand 100 grand okay
but there's two million dollars in there
you put in 100 grand
the rest of the money from 100 up to 2.2
so 2.1 million dollars is growth
on the account if it's in a roth there
is zero taxes on the growth
if it's in a traditional ira or in a
mutual fund
as you would know out retirement
protection
a hundred percent of the growth is taxed
when it comes out if you pay taxes on
2.1 million dollars it's gonna sound
suspiciously like five or six hundred
thousand dollars
so this word roth in this one example
where you're only saving two hundred
dollars a month which is not much
this word roth is worth around six
hundred thousand dollars
so this i want access to it because i
might want to buy something
cost you 600 000
okay so no you you do roth iras
first and foremost when you get to baby
step four
because the tax-free growth and the fact
that the vast majority of what is in
your account when you get to retirement
is growth only a hundred thousand out of
the 2.2 in that example
was principle the rest of it was growth
and zero taxes on the growth
is a six hundred thousand per two
hundred thousand dollar
discussion a per two million dollar
discussion so
it's a lot of freaking money in order to
have
access to it now here's what's
interesting though casey when you start
saving fifteen percent of your income
and you have no debt
and you start doing baby step five and
put your kids college fund away and baby
step six you get your house paid off
oh then we can start investing more and
some of that will be money that you have
access to
i'm not 65 i just turned 60 this year
and i've never touched my retirement
accounts and i've done
tons of other side investing because
i've been out of debt for 30 freaking
years
and you can save invest a lot of money
in addition to your retirement if you
just saved a house payment
so that's what changes the entire
equation right there
so it's a big deal